c'est un village de la région de Kerson
qui brise de rumeurs et de rancoeurs
depuis le départ des forces russes il y
a un mois le seul moment où la
population accepte de se croiser c'est à
la distribution des pensions de retraite
sinon chacun chez soi porte-claude
il y a encore beaucoup de collaborateurs
ici si je pouvais je mettrai la moitié
du village en prison
ceux qui ont collaboré ils habitent à
côté de chez vous il vous nargue tous
les jours c'est infernal je ne comprends
pas que les autorités ne les arrêtent
pas
objet de toutes les accusations ce
couple de fermiers sous le regard ulcéré
de leurs voisins ils ont accueilli des
soldats russes chez eux nous les
interrogeons en caméra discrète
nous on s'adapte à n'importe quelle
autorité la vie sous les Russes c'était
ni moins bien ni mieux que sous les
Ukrainiens on raconte plein d'histoires
sur eux parce qu'on ne les connaît pas
dire avec nous ils n'ont jamais été
menacés on leur a parlé on leur a donné
à manger une première fois et ils sont
revenus il disait que leur chef leur
donnait du pain dur donc ma femme leur a
fait des gâteaux oui je leur ai dit de
manger c'était des gamins j'avais de la
peine pour eux avoir de la sympathie
pour l'ennemi ce n'est pas collaboré
estime-t-il mise au bord du village ils
font actuellement l'objet d'une enquête
tout autour de Carson lors des
règlements de comptes où commence la
collaboration un casse-tête législatif
direction une école du centre-ville la
moitié de l'équipe pédagogique
aujourd'hui en fuite a accepté de
travailler sous les ordres de la Russie
seul reste le gardien il nous emmène
dans la pièce où il a remisé les manuels
scolaires russes
littérature sur le qui-vive il préfère
témoigner anonymement
j'ai travaillé avec les pros russes mais
je n'étais pas un collaborateur
j'ai 72 ans c'était mon seul moyen de
survivre
regardez j'ai conservé mon passeport
ukrainien mais j'ai peur que les
Ukrainiens ne me comprennent pas le
gouvernement a dit que tous les
collaborateurs devaient payer dans cette
lourde atmosphère de soupçons générale
les enquêtes commencent à pied pour
fouiller ce bâtiment occupé 7 mois par
les forces russes l'équipe du procureur
de Carson recherche des preuves un
cuisinier ukrainien a-t-il l'aider les
soldats dans ce capharnaüm des
informateurs venaient-ils livrer des
renseignements ici le moindre indice
compte
l'ADN un mégot de cigarette ou un
coton-tige peuvent nous dire si
désukrainiens ont choisi le camp ennemi
et nous aider à les identifier les
traîtres doivent être punis
la justice a ouvert 18 dossier pour des
faits supposés de collaboration des
investigations délicates la législation
ukrainienne reste encore assez floue